after a six-week Retreat across large
parts of eastern Ukraine the Russian
military has decided to do some PR
Distributing these images of missiles
hurtling towards Targets in harkive and
Kiev that according to their spokesman
and the Man In Charge Vladimir Putin was
carrying a similar message of confidence
and strength into a cavernous Hall in
Kazakhstan
in Astana to meet the leaders of
post-soviet states the Russian president
told them he had no regrets about the
war in Ukraine it would have happened
sooner or later
I want to make it clear what is
happening today is unpleasant to put it
mildly but we would have had the same
thing a little later only with worse
conditions for us so we are acting
correctly and in a timely manner
at least everyone agrees it's unpleasant
over the past few days the Russians have
hit dozens of Civilian targets with
missiles and so-called suicide drones
this apartment complex in zaparisia was
hit overnight
but Western analysts think the Russian
military is running out of advanced
weaponry and they think it lacks trained
Personnel at the front but President
Putin says he solved that problem
despite protests in Russia his recent
troop mobilization is a success
this mobilization is already coming to
an end as of now 222 000 mobilized
Personnel are being integrated into
units of the three hundred thousand I
believe that within two weeks
approximately within two weeks all
mobilization activities will be
completed
as President Putin talks up his
conscripts seen here training for combat
his officials are trying to evacuate
civilians from parts of Ukraine they're
now struggling to hold
we're courageously holding them back
said the deputy head of the occupied
city of Curson but it's dangerous for
life in Kiev the ukrainians have erected
a wall of remembrance for servicemen
who've lost their lives
and they were honored as part of a
ceremony on Defenders Day by the
president the Vladimir zielinski
it is a duty he is likely to repeat
John Sparks Sky News in Ukraine